under Moonlight and the watchful eye of
French police the spring Crossings have
begun
two small boats launch into the darkness
headed to the UK
and as Dawn breaks in Dunkirk another
with dozens of migrants rushing in a
handful left behind
all this amid a record-breaking week for
numbers crossing the channel this year
so far figures and scenes countering the
UK government's pledge to stop the boats
conditions are favorable
favorable provides an opening with more
Crossings and thousands expected in the
months to come
more than 1100 refugees have reached the
UK in small boats in the past week
doubled the capacity of this barge the
home office plans to house migrants in
critics of plans to deter Crossings
among them Rwanda deportation say
they're failing so putting a few hundred
people on the barge or sending a few
token people to Rwanda is pretty it's
really not going to make any realistic
difference to the numbers of people who
want to claim as I'm in the UK and it's
not going to work as a deterrence policy
so we we think you know there's an awful
lot of effort and an awful lot of money
being put in to some of these some of
these schemes and some of these plans
that are not going to make a difference
and it's not just in France numbers
crossing the Mediterranean Sea are
rising a constant stream into Europe
over the weekend saw more than 2 000
rescued
much of the increase may be weather
dependent but the reasons people are
risking their lives haven't changed and
the numbers predicted to attempt
Crossings will rise even further in the
months ahead as mile upon mile of
opportunities stretch along this
Coastline Adele Robinson Sky News